anglophones.
♪ ♪ ♪
de Jennifer Schaeff.
Un chien fidèle pour
une électrice fidèle.
Et cette loyauté devrait
encore uexprimer
le 3 octobre.
es principales
préoccupations : l'accès
à des services en anglais.
Cet électeur de Pointe-Claire
votera aussi encore une fois
sans grand enthousiasme.
- Ça montre encore que
se... est fragilisé.
- Pour ce spécialiste des enjeux
linguistiques, cette élection
sera maranglophone.
CHEDLY BELKHODJA, École affaires
publiqueté Concordia
- On aurait peut-être serré
les rangs si on sentait
d'une majorité libérale.
L'affaib
du Parti libéral permet donc
d'avoir des options.
- We need to repeal Bill 96.
- Le Parti conserv
ne s'est d'ailleurs pas gêné
pour courtiser ouvertement
béraux nous ont
abandonnés ça fait longtemps.
- Un app par par par par par par
cet ancien électeur libéral
qui compte appuyer Éric Dust
un bon gars. À part qu'il doit
de l'argent au gouvernement,
il est pas pire!
- Des formations plus marginales
tendent aussi la main
aux anglophones,
le Bloc Montréal de BalaramaHolr
le vote de cette électrice.
- Parce qu'à Montréal, on a bes.
c'est différent que le reste
du Québec, alors on a besoin
d'avoir des différents
- Ça nous donne plus de choix.
- Cette représentante de la
de ce nouveau paysage politique
it-elle, sit-elle, sit-elle, sin
la démocratie.
EVA LUDVIG, prés. ommunity Grouk
- Nous sommes une communauté
très diverse et nous ne sommes
pas homogènes non plus. On a
- Pour le prouver, suffitde deme
des citoyens rencontrés.
- Le changement climatique.
- Des bons salaire
- Maybe they should stop trying
to divide people.
bon nombre d'anglophones,
c'est l'opposition à la loi 96
du gouvernement Legault, qui
française.
- Par exemple, un
de mariage maintenant doit être
uniquement en français. Aussi,
un peu mesquines. C'est pas
nécessaire pour pr
le français ou protéger
le français.
- Je trouve que la loi
touch"
avec la réalité.
- Cette électrice compte
Québec solidaire, qui a voté
en faveur de la nouvelle loi.
- Beaucoup de partis politiques,
mais il n'y en a p
mes valeurs. Mais quand même,
me voter,
c'est assez important.
- Visiblement, cette fois,
avec résignation.
Ici Mat
Radio-Canada, Montréal.